[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo aplicarse o no la vacuna
contra el kobe 19 cada vez son más las
personas que se sumergen en este dilema
a raíz de un sinnúmero de teorías
conspirativas que se propagan en
internet los gigantes de las redes
sociales acusados de ser negligentes
frente al tema ya han empezado a tomar
medidas al respecto empezamos
a medida que la ciencia se esfuerza para
conseguir una vacuna eficaz contra el
kobe 19 en internet se propagan con
facilidad una serie de teorías sin
fundamento que incitan a la gente a no
vacunarse los gigantes de las redes
sociales que han estado en la mira por
su precaria gestión al respecto están
empezando a tomar sus primeras medidas
facebook anunció una nueva política
global bajo la cual no aceptará en su
plataforma de anuncios pagados que
desalienta en la vacunación sin embargo
no mencionó ninguna estrategia para
restringir las publicaciones que hacen
sus usuarios los grupos antivacunas que
siempre han existido siguen teniendo
fuerte presencia en su plataforma
facebook ha sido acusado de no hacer
nada para regular el contenido dañino
que se propaga en su espacio pero ante
la presión parece haber empezado a
acceder hace unos días anunció la
prohibición de publicaciones que niegan
el holocausto y suprimió contenidos
relacionados con la teoría de
conspiración cubana
nuestro objetivo es ayudar a que los
mensajes sobre la seguridad y la
eficacia de las vacunas lleguen a un
amplio grupo de personas regularmente
refinamos nuestro enfoque en torno a los
anuncios que tratan sobre temas sociales
para capturar debates y discusiones
sobre asuntos delicados que ocurren en
facebook las vacunas no son la excepción
youtube le lleva a facebook una gran
ventaja cuando se trata de estas
políticas hace unos días la compañía
propiedad de google anunció que
eliminaría vídeos que contengan
información errónea sobre la vacuna
contra el cob y 19 esto incluye
afirmaciones sin fundamento de que las
vacunas causan infertilidad o que a
través de ellas se no se implantarán
microchips para controlarnos esta hace
parte de la política que prohíbe
información errónea relacionada con el
kobe 19 desde su transmisión hasta su
tratamiento e incluso la negación de la
existencia del virus bajo esta normativa
y desde principios de febrero se han
eliminado más de 200.000 vídeos el año
pasado youtube des monetizó varios
canales que promovían teorías
conspirativas contra la vacunación se
esperan nuevas restricciones en las
próximas semanas
ahora veamos algunas de las principales
teorías conspirativas que circulan con
respecto a este tema la más antigua tal
vez es esta que las vacunas causan
autismo de acuerdo con la organización
mundial de la salud en 1998 un estudio
planteó una posible relación entre la
vacuna contra el sarampión paperas y
rubéola y el autismo pero la revista que
lo publicó retiró esta teoría porque se
demostró que era fraudulenta hasta el
momento no existe ninguna prueba de ello
otra es la implantación de microchips a
través de las vacunas para controlarnos
el sitio web de verificación de hechos
política consultó al centro para el
desarrollo de vacunas y salud global de
la universidad de maryland su director
el doctor wild bunch y dijo que la
versión más pequeña de un microchip aún
es demasiado grande como para caber por
una aguja otra vez que las vacunas
causan homosexualidad ningún fármaco
puede causar homosexualidad en 1990 90
la organización mundial de la salud dejó
de considerarla como una enfermedad
mental y los especialistas llegaron al
consenso de que esta es una variación
natural de la sexualidad humana
se puede considerar como una condición
patológica
twitter no siguió inmediatamente los
lineamientos de facebook y youtube pero
se sabe que la plataforma ha sido
pionera en combatir las pequeños por
ejemplo ha instalado verificadores de
contenido en los tweets que pueden
contener información poco precisa sobre
el kobe 19 y otros temas también ha
etiquetado como engañosos algunos
mensajes
el presidente estadounidense donald
trump por ejemplo ha visto un gran
número de sus tweets ser censurados por
la red social tras ser dado de alta
después de haber sido diagnosticado con
coronavirus el mandatario emitió un
trino en el que dijo que ahora era
inmune al coronavirus sin embargo se han
registrado lo que serían casos de
infectados alrededor del mundo el mismo
centro para el control y prevención de
enfermedades de eeuu ha informado que
dicha inmunidad no existe
las personas pueden continuar dando
positivo hasta tres meses después del
diagnóstico y no contagiar a otros esta
ciencia no implica que una persona sea
inmune a la reinfección con el sars cop
2 el virus que causa el cob y 19 en los
tres meses posteriores a la infección
los medios de comunicación aplaudieron
las medidas implementadas por las redes
sociales pero han planteado preocupación
por las figuras públicas que alimentan
estas teorías conspirativas en internet
el don de tecnología gizmodo citó una
reciente investigación de la universidad
de harvard que dice que las redes
sociales juegan un papel secundario en
la difusión de teorías de conspiración
citaron el caso del presidente de trump
quien insiste sobre un presunto fraude
en el voto por correo y determinaron que
el mandatario fue el principal impulsor
de estas afirmaciones que luego fueron
amplificadas en la cobertura de medios
tradicionales
el portal de berge rescata por ejemplo
que trump ha hecho declaraciones
públicas presionando por una vacuna en
medio de una campaña por su reelección y
que por ello mucha gente cree que el
proceso de desarrollo de esta vacuna es
político y no científico añade que los
grupos antivacunación es
están alimentando de la desconfianza de
la gente en un artículo de la cadena
británica bbc se preguntan que también
se aplicarán estas nuevas medidas de las
redes sociales que tan efectivas serán
que se podrían llegar demasiado tarde
y para despedir el siguiente dato que
evidencia las consecuencias de la ola de
desinformación en redes sociales de
acuerdo con la revista científica
science una serie de encuestas reveló
que a junio de este año sólo el 50 por
ciento de los estadounidenses estaban
dispuestos a vacunarse contra el cob y
19 cuando exista una vacuna esto luego
de estar expuestos a los rumores de los
grupos antivacunas
hasta aquí y revista digital recuerde
que si quiere repetir esta u otra misión
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer a
través de nuestra página web www punto
francisco atro puntocom
[Música]